übermorgen da ist es endlich soweit das
Sport-Event auf das die ganze Welt seit
Jahren so gar nicht hinfiebert die WM in
Katar jetzt geht's los jetzt geht's los
ja ganz Katar im Fußballfieber meine
Güte mein Tipp mein Tipp die
Einschaltquoten in Deutschland werden
trotzdem wie immer ja natürlich
überlegen Sie mal Wetter ist scheiße es
gibt eine Sehnsucht nach Ablenkung und
auf den anderen Sendern läuft doch auch
nur Mist abgesehen davon ist es meine
ich ernst total frech den moralischen
Druck den Fans vor dem Fernseher
aufzudrücken weil der DFB hat 12 Jahre
am Stück gepennt in Sachen Katar sich
immer nur weggedrückt und und jetzt
sollen die Fenster irgendwas machen ja
was denn ihr seid zwei Jahren aktiv in
interessiert mich für die WM und seit
zwei Jahren treten wir mit meinen
Freunden als gemeinsame Truppe auf wir
spielen nackt fußball
ist krank dafür ziehen wir blank
[Applaus]
das machen die wirklich
es wird den Scheiß eine leere sein dass
da eine Handvoll mittelalte Typen im
Ruhrgebiet mit Wender Banane Fußball
spielt und heute mache ich die Kiste an
und direkt die nächste Horrormeldung zum
Fußball es gibt kein Bier in Katar so
jetzt reicht's ich bin endgültig durch
mit dem Turnier also doch kein Bier mit
Alkohol an den WM Stadien in Katar außer
kein Witz für Fifa Funktionäre und Ihre
Gäste toll und damit sind wir direkt
beim eigentlichen Thema liebe Zuschauer
warum gibt's die FIFA noch
ernstgemeinte Frage meine wir lassen die
Hells Angels auch keine Sport Events
veranstalten ja aber Gianni infant darf
das oder wie warum eigentlich ja warum
seine korrupte Bande wird in Katar
voraussichtlich
6,5 Milliarden Euro Gewinn machen weil
die FIFA als gemeinnützig gilt dabei ist
die ungefähr so gemeinnützig wie der
abou-chaker-clan ja und da darf der Boss
von denen auch noch als Ehrengast beim
G20-Gipfel sprechen meiner Appell an die
Führer der Welt ist denken sie über
einen Waffenstillstand nach für einen
Monat die Dauer der WM
danach könnt ihr euch gerne weiter
umbringen aber versaut mein Sponsoren
nicht das schöne Turnier
diese FIFA behaupte ich ist gar nicht
reformierbar und die WM in Catania nur
der tiefste Punkt einer Kette von
Tiefpunkten auf der FIFA Seite gibt es
jetzt noch ein schönes Spiel zu den
Typen die die WM damals an Katar
vergeben haben da muss ich die exekutiv
Mitglieder finden die noch nicht wegen
Korruption oder anderen Vergehen
gesperrt sind warte mal der vielleicht
nee der ist nicht gesperrt der auch
nicht der auch nicht ja man wer denn
jetzt
ach so nur zwei cool wirklich zwei von
24 sind sauber ja ist doch eine Quote
daher das alte Sprichwort FIFA kann man
nicht sinken
wer jetzt angesichts der bei mir in
Katar immer noch nicht kapiert hat das
ist denen nie um Fußball geht der wohnt
hoffentlich im Heim meine Damen und
Herren
Qatar hat in diese WM unfassbare 200
Milliarden Dollar investiert
das ist umgerechnet ein Deutscher
doppelbums
und bevor wir jetzt hier in die
heuchelfalle tappen natürlich verdienen
auch unsere Firmen mit Siemens hat das
Stromnetz für die Stadien gebaut und der
eigentliche Hammer ist das hier die neue
Metro hunderte Kilometer Schienen
übrigens geplant von der Deutschen Bahn
saubere pünktliche Züge geplant von der
Deutschen Bahn wollt ihr mich verarschen
oder was
[Applaus]
heute ist bahnwäsche immer gar nicht das
Thema gerade hat die FIFA übrigens der
dänischen Nationalmannschaft verboten im
Training Trikots mit der Aufschrift
Menschenrechte für alle zu tragen das
sei eine Zitat FIFA politischer Aussage
ja klar ja das ist ja auch Ansichtssache
ob wirklich jeder solche Rechte hat ne
Homosexuelle zum Beispiel
sie ahnen wahrscheinlich
was jetzt kommt richtig der berühmte
Satz des katarischen wm-botschafters aus
der Jochen Breyer Julia Friedrichs Doku
ist sie finden schwul sein
ich bin kein strenger Muslim aber warum
ist es heran es ist ein geistiger
schaden
seitdem hat man nichts mehr von Jochen
Breyer gehört meine Damen und Herren
schade war ein guter Mann der britische
Außenminister fordert queere Fußballfans
auf sich in Katar respektvoll zu
verhalten eben man kann noch mal für
vier Wochen aufhören mit schwul sein das
muss doch möglich sein oder einfach mal
eine schwule Pause machen
das kriminalisieren von Homosexualität
ist aber keine kulturelle Eigenheit die
man respektieren muss gar nicht was
Frauenrechte angeht müssen wir sagen
gibt's Licht und Schatten einerseits
brauchen katarische Frauen noch einen
männlichen Form und um zum Beispiel zu
reisen oder zu studieren andererseits
hat Katar sogar eine Frau
Nationalmannschaft ja weil das die FIFA
Statuten von allen wm-bewerbern
verlangen also hat man 2009 eine
gegründet dann ging die WM an Katar und
seitdem ist das Team irgendwie weg ja
existiert nur auf dem Papier hier
katarische Sportschau mit Frauenfußball
und da läuft sie nicht denn sie ist ja
zu Hause niemand läuft in den freien
Raum da müsste eine stehen aber da steht
keine jetzt noch mal kein Eckball die
Flanke kommt nicht kein Kopf verloren
ganz knapp oder Spiel ist auch seit acht
Jahren sind unsere Frauen ungeschlagen
also im Stadion zu Hause natürlich nicht
ja
verschwundene Frauen Nationalmannschaft
gut was für gerade gesehen haben immer
noch besser als Deutschland gegen Oman
haben sie es geguckt 90 Minuten pure
lebenszeitverschwendung oder haben
unsere Jungs absichtlich so schlecht
gespielt als politisches Statement nein
wie schade ja auch von der Hansi Flick
und Co erwarten jetzt alle dass sie in
Katar irgendwelche Zeichen setzen dafür
ist es aber zig Jahre zu spät aber jetzt
noch bleibt ist folgenlose Symbolpolitik
wobei Zeit dafür hätten sie ja denn das
Freizeitangebot rund ums deutsche
Quartier naja die Nationalmannschaft hat
dort dann auch ihren eigenen Bereich so
dass man mit normalen Hotelgästen die
zusammen kommt aber ansonsten trifft das
glaube ich ein bisschen der Stichwort
wir können uns das hier drumherum mal
anschauen viel gibt es hier nicht zu
sehen und nicht zu tun also was Ausflüge
angeht wieso
man kann sich Steine angucken oder
verschiedene Arten von sans ne
hauptsache man trifft keine normalen
so und wir schalten jetzt mal live ins
DFB Trainingslager wo dieser Flagge den
Nationalspielern genau jetzt einen
letzten Crashkurs verpasst in Sachen
Zeichen setzen für Menschenrechte dieser
wie läuft es denn so
sehr gut Oliver ich bin angenehm
überrascht wie gut die Jungs sich doch
konzentrieren können okay ich sehe
gerade drei bis fünf von denen sind
jetzt wieder am Handy und spielen Candy
crush obwohl wir eigentlich was anderes
vereinbart haben könnt ihr euch in einer
Stunde wieder abholen so was zur Hölle
ist only Fans
egal so wo war ich ach ja richtig bei
der One Love Armbinde die unser Manu
neuer im Tor tragen wird was soll der
Scheiß denn bitte bei der EM letztes
Jahr hat er noch eine richtige
Regenbogenfahne getragen und jetzt wo es
drauf ankommt irgendwelche bunten Farben
nur damit die scheiß sich nicht in den
Kaftan machen und Manuel
wenn du schon ein Interview zu dieser
Armbinde gibst dann vielleicht ein
bisschen mehr Pep sehr schön wir hoffen
natürlich dass wir durch die
überlaufbinde viel Power
gleich mal platzieren können ja sag ich
mal viel schnarchiger kann man sich
jetzt nicht verkaufen
typisch mutiger DFB deshalb ja auch das
neue protest-fanshirt
hdgdl minus wow das klingt ja genau wie
lgbtq+ nur halt mit völlig anderen
Buchstaben geht's noch wie kann man sein
ich sage noch mal was ich von euch
erwarte bei der WM Aktionen ich habe
hier mal ein paar Praktikanten
mitgebracht die zeigen euch jetzt wie
man Tore in catabi jubelt um ein echtes
Zeichen zu setzen also
passive und Torschütze fallen sich in
die Arme und fangen an hemmungslos zu
knutschen Minuten lang quer über den
Platz bis der Emir rollt während der
Außenverteidiger einen extrem erotischen
Eckfahnen Tanz aufführt ich will ein
kleiner wackeln sehen los
und wenn ihr wirklich was tun wollt für
Menschenrechte wie wäre es denn wenn
jeder von euch im Fall dass wir im
Titels seine 400.000 Euro Siegprämie
einfach spendet an den
Entschädigungsfonds für die
Arbeitsmigranten
[Gelächter]
der war gut ne immer mit dem Geld
aufhören zurück nach Köln
[Applaus]
ja gut meine
immerhin auf der Habenseite reden wir
hier von der ersten klimaneutralen
Weltmeisterschaft überhaupt
behauptet zumindest die FIFA will sagen
ist natürlich auch gelogen sie haben
sich gedacht ja
CO2-Emissionen werden hauptsächlich
durch billige CO2-Zertifikate
ausgeglichen geprüft von einer Agentur
die Katar gehört ja und alles was sie
ansonsten zum Klima dort wissen müssen
sagt diese Meldung auch das Team des
Gastgebers ist eingetroffen Katar hatte
sich in Spanien auf Katar vorbereitet
wahrscheinlich Weizen der Heimat einfach
zu heiß ist
wahrscheinlich ja macht nichts gespielt
wird ja ab Sonntag in klimatisierten
Stadien von den mindestens eins nach der
WM direkt wieder abgebaut wird aber
keine Angst das geht kinderleicht denn
das Ding ist von Ikea so und sind wir
doch mal ganz ehrlich ab Sonntag reden
die meisten noch sowieso wieder nur noch
über Sport die Vorfreude in Katar dieser
ja alt ehrwürdigen Fußballnation ist
jedenfalls gigantisch in entsprechende
Landesfarben gesteckt machen sie
Stimmung auf Zeit wie zum Beispiel am
Wochenende bei Medientermin einige haben
hier schon auf den wm-baustellen
gearbeitet nun heißt es also Minijob
Fußballfan
mein Gott was müssen diese Menschen noch
ertragen erst bauen sie unter
schlimmsten Bedingungen Stadien mitten
in der Wüste und jetzt müssen sie
besoffene Engländer spielen
wobei ich schon zugeben muss die
deutschen Fenster die werden teilweise
ganz realistisch dargestellt denn wenn
das hier kein klassischer deutscher
trachtentanz ist dann weiß ich auch
nicht mehr ja das legendäre deutsche
Rhythmusgefühl
um das uns die ganze Welt beneidet ja
zusätzlich werden auf sicher übrigens
noch rund 500 echte Fans aus dem Ausland
eingekauft und eingeflogen die kriegen
Flug und Tickets wohl bezahlt müssen
dafür aber versprechen nur nette Sachen
über Katar zu posten alles kritische
wird sofort gelöscht kurz gesagt ne ganz
normale WM und dennoch hat das Emirat
für Sprecher in diesen Tagen auch aus
Deutschland kommt immer wieder wenn Sie
darauf achten er Schützenhilfe wie geht
das wir schalten mal live nach Doha wo
Dennis knossalla die passende Agentur
betreibt Dennis welchen Service bieten
sie da an ganz einfach ich vermittle den
Kataris deutsche Top Lobbyisten gegen
einen Arsch voll Geld so nennt sich die
Währung hier
einfach anrufen bei rented German unser
Slogan soll es mit deinem Image laufen
musst du dir einen deutschen kaufen
heute im Angebot unser Modell Siggi ein
ehemaliger Außenminister top erhalten
Scheckheft gepflegt also also im
wahrsten Sinne des Wortes denn er sitzt
ja von Katars Gnaden im Aufsichtsrat der
Deutschen Bank und zum Dank gibt er
jetzt mal was zurück der frühere
Außenminister und SPD-Politiker Sigmar
Gabriel ist schon 40 über die seiner
Meinung nach arrogante deutsche
Diskussion rund um das WM Gastgeberland
statt die Reformen des golfstaates zu
loben würden die Deutschen das Emiraten
nur beleidigen
Bravo catar wird fies gemobbt Gabriel
Twitter zu Recht angewandte
Homosexualität war auch in Deutschland
bis
1994 strafbar ja aber nur mit
Minderjährigen und wenn ich mich richtig
erinnere niemand wurde zur Strafe
ausgepeitscht wie kann man das denn
vergleichen keine Ahnung für Geld aber
bitte wenn sie gehen nichts für sie ist
hätte ich noch was ganz feines im
Angebot ich darf nicht zu viel verraten
aber er war mal Boss bei einem
beliebigen deutschen Rekordmeister mehr
sage ich nicht denn er möchte anonym
bleiben nennen wir ihn mal Heinz Karl
riminocken
der war erst gegen die Winter WM dann
kam er nach Doha und hat zwei Rolex
geschenkt bekommen unter anderem diese
geschmackvolle Damenuhr Modell
Augenkrebs und seitdem ist er für die WM
ich mag Zufall sein und er sagt auch die
Uhr hat ihm irgendein Freund geschenkt
aber wie heißt es beim Fußball
entscheidend ist auf dem Konto ja
Lobbyarbeit für zwei potthässliche Uhren
erstens das wurde nie bewiesen zweitens
hat der FC Bayern ja auch noch diesen
wunderbaren Sponsoren Deal mit
Qatar Airways WINWIN Bayern wird noch
reicher und schickt dafür regelmäßig
einen vorbestraften würstchenfabrikanten
in den Doppelpass und eines ist doch
auch sicher wenn wir morgen aufhören mit
Katar Geschäfte zu machen glauben
Sie dass es dann den den den Arbeitern
besser geht nein so den Arbeitern geht's
scheiße und deshalb nehmen wir doch
lieber das Geld aus Katar bevor es noch
irgendjemand anders kriegt ah ich sehe
schon Ulli ist auch nichts für sie dann
empfehle ich Ihnen unser Modell
Olli die heute-show ist nämlich eben
gekauft worden vom katarischen
comedy-sender derera bitte das wusste
ich aber
Moment wo kommen wir plötzlich die Uhren
her ja so schnell geht das
[Applaus]
at wir haben gesagt die sollen meinen
Lieblingswitz erzählen was mache ich
gerne also kommen ein Pferd Jeff Bezos
und der Papst in eine Bar sagt der
Barkeeper abonniert endlich denn
verkackten heute
schon also geht doch